welcome back to the Julian podcast where
we are above water no longer beneath the
surface of the ocean this week's episode
is brought to you by Squarespace guys
Squarespace
makes the process of creating your
beautiful website a seamless reality
okay
they have 24/7 customer support plenty
of templates and ways to making your own
website right now go to Squarespace calm
slots Jenna doing you get 10% off your
first purchase of a website or domain
guys if you're intimidated about
starting a website Squarespace is the
way to go they will help you also guys
brought to you by quip is a new awesome
convenient toothbrush at an affordable
price start such as $25 and it's the
sleekest design you've ever seen for an
electric toothbrush it's not clunky or
big it's nice it looks like it was made
by Apple right now you can get your
first refill pack for free and get quick
calm that's GE tqu IP cop / annejulien
or click the link in our description
thank you sponsors gracias
ell sponsors I majored in Spanish that's
correct
yo soy peligro yo soy peligro well we
are recording this a little bit early
this week because I'm gonna be gone but
actually by the time you're watching
this I'll be back today I'm gonna be
going to Minneapolis to do stuff for
Super Saturday night and the Super Bowl
and all sorts of cool stuff but I'm
gonna be gone for a couple days so
so is that I'm gonna have a bad time
without you're gonna be so jealous okay
I know it takes so many pictures of me
and my hamster just having a great time
can you send him to me are you gonna cry
yeah I would cry too cries I'm cold
Oh cry the second he comes out I'll just
start crying cuz he's just so handsome
that I love him so much good goddamn boy
well we got today so I thought that we
would do a weird things podcast again
but then as I like looked for things and
got a lot of suggestions from one of you
they kind of turned into just unsolved
mysteries so I think we'll call this
unsolved mysteries with Jenna Julianne
right this will be missing people yeah
yeah well I solve mysteries some of them
are not missing like the bodies were
found but just the way that everything
happened is very confusing or there's
not a lot of like nothing's conclusive
about these cases it's going to you
scary podcast quickly and and what's
cool is quickly I want to shout out
invented at invented by Jenna her name's
Kayla on Twitter she gave us a whole
thread of her favorite unsolved
mysteries and we only got about I don't
even know how far down she has so many
more in that threat so if we fly through
these we can just pop her thread open
but and look and look there's like so
many of them and it dates back to late
2017 so Thank You Kayla for all these
suggestions well you're gonna go through
some of these unsolved mysteries I've
gathered them I did a little research
and I put some information on paper so
where we could talk about them basically
they're just unsolved mysteries and
we're gonna talk about them give our
opinions of what we think happened what
we think went down it's not quite
conspiracy theories it's not quite weird
things it's somewhere in the middle I
was a little bit scared as I was
compiling these some of these are a
little creepy a candle or a flashlight
I'm scared it's dark in here it's very
dark oh that's much better thank you
okay I feel safe now okay with the
flashlight on your phone in this bright
bright light room yes I feel better you
are welcome thank you
the first one up is
the Jameson family yes so Julian did the
research for these he told me what they
were I don't really know what they are
yet so I'm I'm scared and excited I'll
just sort of read them I'm just like
everybody listening I'm scared and
excited grab a blanket I don't have one
I need a snack too I got a lot of this
from reddit for this one
so Bobby cherylin Bobby and Sheryl and
Jamison were husband and wife and they
vanished in October of 2009 with their
daughter Madison the family was on a
trip supposedly according to their
family to buy a new home and were
reported missing days after leaving Hunt
said journey the remains were found four
years later with inconclusive results so
that's a short story long story does not
usually mean when it says inconclusive
results like they're not able to tell if
it was a homicide or like how they died
or they don't know how they died they
don't know what the cause of death was
yeah they don't know the cause of death
by the time they've discovered there
remains a lot of times you can't like
run toxology you don't know if they had
drugs in them right like we a said four
years later yeah okay so but basically
they can't tell how they died yeah okay
so a couple things one is they were
assumed to be meth users because they
were emaciated they oftentimes had
delusions their family their family
backed up that that fact and and that
they were you know kind of like just out
there with what they would say Bobby
actually was I think he told someone in
his church I believe that he was having
delusions of hauntings he was quoted
saying that he was reading a Satanic
Bible and that he was seeking special
bullets to do battle with spirits
stop and a lot of the stuff was kind of
viewed and in retrospect as like cult
language so
yes that they yes they were likely meth
users yes they likely were hi
experiencing weird illusions but it is
possible that there is some sort of cult
thing involved which actually circles
back to their mom it didn't specify if
it was his mom or her mom but one of
their mom's cherylin or Bob's mom had an
interesting theory that basically was
backing up the cult thing that it was
that they were put on some sort of cult
hit list and as they went out to look
for their house or do whatever they said
they were gonna do that's when they were
offed by said cult leader or cult
murderers or whatever really quickly
though why would a cult leader wanna
kill their cult members well maybe they
had maybe they had done something are
they barking I don't know I heard about
I don't know maybe they had done
something I don't know who knows but
just a couple facts right so duh
three or I think three or four days
after three days after their their
disappearance their truck was found and
their dog was in the truck alive
thankfully almost dead malnutrition and
everything but the dog was in the truck
for three days survived also in the
truck was thirty two thousand dollars in
cash car keys GPS and both of their
phones on their phones were these
pictures I was actually just that
picture that was Madison their dogs just
a picture of how old is she she looks
like five yeah yeah I actually don't
know if she was young she was probably
under eight years old but this was taken
a picture of her sitting in the woods
you can sort of see it if you look this
up you you'll find it but basically it's
she looks a little bit in distress in
this picture you see she's it's not the
greatest picture I think the family had
a problem with that picture being
released to the public because it looked
like the daughter was mistreated or she
was upset or something it's not that
it's not a happy family picture of the
daughter she looks a little like upset
well yeah in the picture to the right
she looks close to the same age but has
her two front teeth and the left one she
doesn't have her front teeth that could
be just normal she lost her teeth that
could be like three months apart she
would lose her little yeah but other
than that I don't see anything why they
wouldn't she just looks like a little
girl yeah I mean she doesn't
but again photos of kids oftentimes look
upset right you got arms cross yeah yeah
and so for three and a half years three
and a half or four years they went
undiscovered they didn't know where
their bodies were they didn't know what
happened there was a whole entire search
party that went through the land of
which they were going which was actually
private land which was part of the
theory that they were going to invest in
a house that's what they that was kind
of their alibi what state was this is
the United States this was in the United
States actually don't I had it earlier I
remember I the woods it doesn't matter
yeah it's it's kind of whatever anyway
they had said that they were going to
invest in property heads the cash or
whatever right and I think that was one
of the alibis that they had or that they
their family was backing up or whatever
who invests in property in cash flow
this is 2009 yes they were driving out
into this private privately owned land
okay a whole search party was conducted
swept the whole hill swept miles and
miles outside of the radius of the car
was found nothing how far was the car
from from their bodies they didn't have
their bodies for four years so four
years later miles and miles away Oh far
away from the car yeah there's actually
a map where you can see it triangulated
where everything is a hunter found three
skeletons lying perfectly side-by-side
face down the DNA confirmed via you know
tests that that was them it was all
three of them and so that's kind of
where the story Ed's there's a lot of
theories on it
there's the cult theory there's the
theory that and there was a boat there
was sorry not there was a hole in
Bobby's skull but it wasn't just like
you know a hole in bobby skull bullet it
wasn't like that conclusive there were a
lot of reasons that there could have
been a hole who there could have been
wildlife eating at the corpses there
could have been rotting there's a whole
number of things that could have
contributed to it also wasn't a
perfectly bullet Li shaped bullet shaped
hole
and also it was four years later so so
many different types of you know
breakdown could have happened to the
human skull but there was there was a
hole in Bobby skull there was also I
think backed up by her ther family sure
sherilyn had a gun that was not in the
truck meaning that there could have been
a gunshot to his head and it could have
been Cheryl ins again very kind of foggy
I found a theory that was interesting on
reddit bypassed the mash this is three
years ago posted to Reddit one he was
killed that they were killed by a
sociopath with a rifle overall rifle
though yeah I'll read the whole I'll
just read this whole comment overall I
can't see a killer wasting his or her
time accompanying the Jameson's through
the woods which would be necessary if we
envisioned most traditional methods
pistol knife strangulation but I can't
see an evil individual doing this as a
random killing a homicide of opportunity
perhaps someone with a rifle spotted
them from a distance they were just
going hiking and decided to enact some
sort of sniper fantasy mmm maybe uh but
that wouldn't explain why their bodies
are laid out next to each other yes and
they're all it also should be noted that
there are mudslides in the area so the
reasons the reason that hunter probably
stumbled across the Bata
the skeletons laying on top of the
ground is probably because the mud sides
like washed away what they were buried
underneath it's possible yes they
wouldn't just be laying there for four
years with no one noticing I'm likely
that's possible yeah a third that far
into the woods mm-hmm
number two I don't I don't love number
one honestly because I can't see taking
a six year old hike six year old on a
plus or minus three-mile hike but when
you're a nefarious killer guiding the
jameson's at gunpoint or when the
Jameson's parent parents interested in
exploring the woods you don't want to
undertake that journey with Madison it
can only lead to misery for everyone
involved so this leads me to consider
the grim possibility that I haven't seen
anyone else on this thread mentioned
namely be as vague as possible that
Madison died on top of the mountain near
the truck and was carried into the woods
by her parents who decided to join her
in the
rest once they arrived at the spot where
their bodies could lie together very
privately in peace so those are two
theories I found that we're just
interesting because obviously you have
the you have the theory that the like
they the cherylin had a gun off Bobby
and then whatever else happened or then
you have the theory of the a random
killing but then you have the suspicions
of like the coke thing which is really
weird to me but you have to remember
that they were meth users yeah I feel
like my yeah I think the point that no
one even if they had that cache of the
whole we're gonna invest in land a sort
of a decoy to their families that
they're you know they owe somebody money
or they're in some kind of trouble like
I mean it is possible that somebody
wanted to get them as far as from land
you know where people travel and hang
out at as possible three miles is pretty
far you know yeah to walk them in there
or to carry them in there I feel like
it's more plausible that whatever he was
reading or like into even if she had a
gun he probably used the gun if it's if
she's not into that stuff and it's just
him but they're both meth users they
convince each other that they're gonna
go do some satanic [ __ ] in the woods and
they decide to all die together
it could have been something planned or
weird like that that's what I'm yeah I
mean it's delaying the laying parallel
to each other I mean if if a hunter or a
bad person with a gun kills a random
group of people well if somebody killed
someone with a rifle you there would be
like forensic evidence of that right you
don't think that's something on their on
their skeletons would lead to point to
something like that yeah you know like
it's three years it's not a hundred
years right this thing didn't break down
like a skeleton does over years and
years it was three or four three and a
half four years I don't know I mean that
one for me is like that's so sad it's
sad but the wild-card for me is like
it's the the drug use you know cuz it
could have been any number of things
they could have even been involved in
selling or dealing drugs and could have
gotten mixed up with the wrong people
hence tried to escape and then got
caught or something
yeah by their long leaders or boss or
whatever I guess the weird thing about
you know even if they were like alright
we're gonna go out to the woods and
mommy and daddy are gonna kill
themselves and we're gonna take you with
us like why would they leave their dog
and all that cash in the car you know if
this was someone that wanted that money
and was you know expecting them to give
them money or something why wouldn't
they take the cash or like well the car
was described as if they had left in a
hurry
that's what I'm saying yeah so either
they were having crazy delusions and
running away from huffing that's
possible or they were really running
away from something dangerous that
caught them yeah it's really sad
it is sad well I don't have a solution
for that one I guess we'll just leave
that one unsolved tears oh yeah I mean
if it's unsolved its unsolved we're not
gonna sit we're not gonna sit here we're
just giving our two cents just really
sad it's sad this next one is gnarly
you ready what's your best gift I'm not
done that's sad
I don't have a best guess I just think
it's I think it's such a wild card with
the drug use I think they were the cash
to me makes me feel like they were
involved in drugs yeah who lists $32,000
of cash laying around nobody in 2009 in
2009 but also just like and supposedly
she had a gun right oh and there was
another point of like cherylin would
often write letters to Bob of like anger
and like frustration so there was
definitely strife between the two and
the mother confirmed this but that's not
really pointing to anything right that's
just kind of like normal I mean I'm
normal but there's no there's no that
doesn't lead anything that's just I
don't know maybe they really were
planning on investing in property and
then they got in a big messy meth fight
in the car and when killed each other
but my thing is well as a meth user
we'll just died of exposure out there
it's possible you know like if they got
in a fight or something what if they
were like chasing some delusion or some
fake thing I mean I'm sure Don met
oh really know what that's restless you
here's a theory okay they were getting
in a fight the problem with this is like
I have a hard time believing a meth user
or two meth users too heavy meth users
would leave behind cash that's that's
their ticket to the next high
I don't leave behind cash unless you
you're planning on dying or something or
it's over or you're having the weirdest
trip ever not trip but you're just going
through a weird what do you call it when
you're not enough you're high as [ __ ]
and you do you like you you're thinking
everything's over and so like you have
you must have to be crazy high out of
your mind on that stuff to leave behind
thirty to thirty two thousand dollars of
cash because that's your ticket to
staying high right don't meth users feel
like I'll do anything for the next well
yeah we can all agree that it wasn't
their intention to leave their money in
the car and go die so you think that
they were having a crazy trip they went
out in a hurry
I'm just saying it's possible oh yeah
I'm just trying to fight but they had
the daughter with them yeah it's
possible that they killed each other or
a murder-suicide and the little girl
like didn't was so far away and in the
woods that she sort of just stayed with
their bodies and didn't know what to do
and just lay down next to the died of
exposure of thirst hunger see exhaustion
hmm so the daughter might have died
after I said it before possible it's
possible that they all died of different
causes yeah I agree
if one overdose and then died in the
woods and then the father killed himself
or what if the mother killed the father
then she died because she was high on
meth and where it [ __ ] up and I'm the
girl died last or something like you
said yeah it's just really sad I feel
like I'm in I could never be a police
officer it would be too sad all the time
this feel bad for a little girl man your
parents are drug users and mmm sucks
it's an unfortunate one
this one the next one is pretty [ __ ]
this is a the case of ELISA Lam I know
what this one is
sources Wikipedia there's videos of them
yeah we get to that okay Lisa Lam was
found dead in the water tank on top of
the Cecil then called the Cecil Hotel in
Los Angeles in 2013 it's five years ago
guys security footage of her before she
went missing was her pushing multiple
buttons peering in and out as if he was
looking for someone in motioning a very
strange way as if she's talking to
someone in and out of the elevator and
in the hallways hotel guests this
hopefully you're not eating right now
hotel guests began to complain about the
taste and color of the water which led
to the discovery of the body inside the
water tank on top of the hotel there
were complaints that it tasted weird and
that it was coming out black she had
bipolar disorder which is a huge huge
point in this story but many people
claim the video was altered before being
released which is another interesting
point there's sort of an account here
that it's a little bit long and lengthy
but I think it's important to the story
so I'm gonna read it okay it's about the
security footage in the clip the camera
is at at one of the elevators cabs rear
corner and it looks down from the
ceiling offering a view of not just its
interior but the hallway outside it's
pretty grainy the timestamp at the
bottom is obscured and at certain points
her mouth is pixelized and this is the
video that was released from the hotel
to the public at the start land enters
in red zippered hooded sweatshirt over a
grey t-shirt with black shorts and
sandals she enters from the left and
goes to the control panel appears I
think they were referring to the buttons
right on the elevator appears to select
several floors and then steps back into
the corner after a few seconds during
which the door fails to close she steps
up to it leans forward so her head is
through the door looks in both
directions then quickly steps back in
backing up to the wall and then to the
corner near the control panel the door
remains open she walks to do it again
and stands in the in the doorway leaning
on the side suddenly she steps
to the hall then to her side then back
in looking side to side and back out and
back inside the elevator and just for a
few seconds when she steps sideways
she's mostly invisible behind the wall
outside the elevator and she has her
back to the outside the door remained
open her arm can be seen going up to her
head and then she turns to reenter the
cab putting both hands on the side of
the door and then goes to the control
panel panel presses many more buttons
some more than once and then returns to
the wall where she is partially obscured
then she puts both of her hands over her
ears briefly as she walks back to the
section of the wall that she had been
standing against before the door remains
up and she turns to her right begins
rubbing her forearms together and waves
her hands out to her sides with her
palms flat fingers outstretched while
bowing forward slightly and rocking
gently this can all be seen through the
door which remains open as she backs to
the wall again and walks away to the
left it closes so she she has this whole
sort of weird encounter with herself
where she's walking in and out of the
elevator checking down the hallway
looking up looking down raising your
arms pressing buttons going you in the
corner and repeating over and over and
over and it's all on camera but the door
will not close she then walks away and
then the door closes creepy absolutely
creepy the fact that that's on video is
creepy yeah that's why I was saying the
video you can find those videos on your
own I have screenshots videos I saw some
of it online yeah it's pretty famous
video footage at this one there were the
toxology you know and and the autopsy
had no evidence of drugs or sexual
assault or suicide she was found in the
water tank floating aside her belongings
and clothes and that's that's [ __ ] it
wasn't there like it's incredibly
difficult to get up to that water yes
sorry yes good call there okay so the
water tanks really high up the the lid
to the top of the water tank is
incredibly heavy it usually requires two
people to get you know access to it
there was no ladder found and it's very
hot like you can't climb this thing
that was a good point the water take
itself was mounted on cinder blocks so
the water tank isn't flush on the ground
it's it's elevated so getting on top of
this thing seems like a really really
hard and then probable for one young
woman at least without help yeah yeah
good good point I forgot to mention that
and again no ladder no no any sort of
structure where they could have assumed
that she got up from yeah I'm not um
maybe this is an unpopular opinion
because I'm not buying any bipolar like
even if she was diagnosed with bipolar
depending what kind of bipolar she had I
think it you do you can have manic
episodes but it's not this like you get
into an elevator and the elevator
doesn't close that to me is out of the
ordinary well what do you have to what I
agree devil's a view here though why
would her mouth be pixelized pixelated
that so some of this seems pretty a
little creepy almost ghost or EE but
then some of that feels like a cover-up
like what could could there could there
have been like because again they said
specifically the wall she was standing
against made her made it so she's like
part of her was not visible to the
camera is it possible that there was
another camera angle showing a whole
nother side of this interaction with
maybe another person that was never
released maybe and when they blurred her
mouth that was her saying someone's name
that they could have maybe discovered
upon reading that tape over and over
even still though like how did she get
up in that water tower how she got up in
the water towers is weird it's weird man
I don't the fact that like this is the
last footage of her right is in the
elevator isn't that hotel also known to
be relatively haunted I don't know
they've since changed their name I know
that there was a whole bunch of loss
who's after this happened both from her
family and the guests of the hotel
I'm sure yeah if you think so I'm sure
you're right I just recalled yeah I
didn't look into the hotel but I'm sure
you know I spent only so much time on
each of these stories so I'm sure
there's a lot more information and that
goes for all these stories like if I
miss something or we got all those I'm
wrong I apologize I just the last time
that I had watched that footage it was
like really creepy hmm to the point
where it's like okay she could totally
be diagnosed with bipolar but this
doesn't read bipolar behavior to me this
reads like there's something real creepy
going on to me well bipolar is one thing
but what I mean having a manic episode
where you're seeing your would you call
it delusional when your depends what
kind of bipolar she has but it's not
always are there certain types of
bipolar where you see things that aren't
there
that's not like polar like schizophrenia
yeah that's what I think too and I know
nothing oh you guys correct me it's been
a long time since I was in school but I
didn't think so
it's just more of the UH like a manic
sort of you're you're on a high and and
then you crash sort of mm-hmm and then
you have depressive episodes it's really
bad yeah no I know I know I've seen the
behavior it doesn't seem like well a
manic episode for a schizophrenic though
is sometimes delusions the yes that kind
of thing but they didn't mention that
sure well she maybe she wasn't diagnosed
with that but they eat that it's
possible that she was just hallucinating
and having you know seeing things
hearing voices talking to people that
weren't there but how did she get in
that water
how did she get in water showers the
biggest mystery for me is like if
there's like the lid was on right she
was in the round dead and the lid was on
she was in that thing so if we're really
stretching here she might have been
talking to a ghost that was threatening
her if she didn't do something she was
gonna end up dead and the ghosts way of
killing her was putting her in the water
tank right like that's the creepy kind
of unknown part cuz if she was just
found dead or she had jumped
the building or heard when missing I
mean a lot of that you could sort of
like you know you could sort of
rationalize that she might have been
killed in any sort of normal way but to
have her be dead inside this water tag
and floating next to her clothes and
belongings why next to why was she
wearing she was naked yeah and so
everything was floating okay that makes
no sense and the fact that the
investigative unit did not find a single
piece of evidence pointing to the fact
that she could have hoisted herself up I
mean if she got in that water tank I'm
sure she could have done it with help
right like it doesn't seem like she just
what I'm saying is it doesn't seem like
she got into a place where it was
otherwise impossible physically to get
into it's a water tank yes it's very
unlikely and really hard to believe and
almost impossible for one person get
themselves in there without any ladder
or something like that but the tank
itself with the right assistance can be
entered right of course I mean I I don't
know what the water tank looked like but
like where I grew up there was a place
with big water tanks like that it's it
subsea like face like it's metal you
can't climb up it and even if someone
had like put me on their hands and like
cheerleader threw me into the air it's
still difficult to get in there and
there if there's no ladder you know what
I mean those things are built like that
for a reason yeah it's hard to believe
someone who's having such a weird
episode like yelling potentially at
themselves right or someone that we
don't see mm-hmm his cognitive cognitive
enough to get themselves so physically
you know demanding we I imagine some
people's argument is like that's how she
got herself up there is because maybe
she was having a manic episode or you
know she was capable she was capable of
anything I don't know hmm
to me the whole thing just seems really
really really
really creepy mmm that is creepy cuz
it's like it's it's almost too bizarre
to even be like a murder it's uncle it's
the weirdest creepiest thing ever
yeah I just I don't know that the fact
that the door does the whole thing yet
that's that's to me is like there's
maybe there's not even anything going on
with her at all like she's like rocking
back and forth there's weird it's like
dealing with something on the hotel that
elevator door wasn't closing
that's not her that has nothing to do
with her and she just keeps walking in
and out and rocking back and forth and
like rubbing her arms together
no thank you I don't know man all of
that seems so creepy to me let go stuff
to me but there aren't like there's
almost no aside from people saying that
a demon attacked them and stuff isn't it
there's very few times when ghosts have
actually hurt people is that am I making
that up I thought that was the thing no
I think I think you're right I think
there's a link there's far more accounts
of people interacting with ghosts that
haven't been hurtin by them then there
are people interacting getting physical
they've gotten scratches and stuff from
ghosts and demons but like a ghost
actually hurting someone I thought was
really really really uncommon or telling
them I agree I agree if it's even
possible well I mean I could be up all
night looking at this story and finding
more facts about it cuz it's really
interesting that stuff's again just
really all the way sad though how old is
she son ug she was young look at her
maybe late 20s early 30s hmm that
footage is just it's so much let's talk
about squarespace Julia well I wasn't
gonna transition I felt like it was
anyway if you're building your website
and you're up all night I try not to be
disrespectful trying to build your
website and you need help it
the thing about Squarespace having 24/7
customer support is the people who build
websites at least what I think the
people who build websites who
entrepreneurs who are their own bosses
who are working from home a lot of times
they're not working traditional hours
and even if you are working traditional
hours right this point goes both ways if
you're working it in 12:00 noon or if
you're working at 12:00 midnight it
doesn't matter
you need help building your website
because it's it's freaking hard to build
a website not with Squarespace okay they
make it easy and any little question any
little piece of information any tweak
any template coding whatever you need
help with 24/7 they're there for you
guys that's one of the amazing things
about Squarespace award-winning customer
support 24/7 that's my favorite thing
about Squarespace we currently have a
website with Squarespace I told you and
you know what it's one of those things
where in your brain it's a lot more
daunting to start the website than it
actually is with Squarespace they make
it very easy they make it you can have
an online store you can sell products or
services online they allow you to manage
your manager products orders an
inventory very easily it's an all-in-one
platform that you that you can use to
run your business it's amazing okay with
the customer support think it dream it
make it with Squarespace by going to
squarespace.com slash Jenna Julianne to
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain and for our other
sponsor this week guys quip how often
you use your toothbrush for way too long
or do you keep forgetting to buy a new
one or are you just lazy
honestly 75% of us don't replace our
bristles every three months that's why
you need a new electric toothbrush that
is called quip it is backed by a network
of over 10,000 dental professionals it
will be love at first brush and better
oral hygiene at an affordable price it
starts at just 25 bucks and it's the
sleek is design you've ever seen four
electric toothbrush you don't have to
worry about forgetting to replace the
brush heads because they get delivered
to you on schedule delivered right to
your front door they have the little
refill packs with the fresh bristles so
you can keep your mouth nice and fresh
especially when you're making good
transitions into the sponsors right now
when you go to get quip comm that's GE
tqu IP tom slash Jenna Julianne you'll
get your first refill pack for free
with an electric quip to
brush check it out guys it's great
product and it's it's just simple a lot
of times you just need to simplify
things quick does that okay check it out
click the link in the description thank
you sponsors thank you
eyes have a clarification from this
story you can have hallucinations with
bipolar it didn't specify bipolar one or
two you can have them as visual auditory
tactile olfactory or kinesthetic
hallucinations are more likely to be
auditory than visual and people with
bipolar disorder you're more likely to
have hallucinations if you experience a
severe mood swings hallucinations and
other psychotic symptoms are also more
likely to happen with those with
schizophrenia rather than those with
bipolar disorder that's why people with
bipolar disorder who have hallucinations
can be incorrectly diagnosed tada
so this says that it auditory
hallucinations are more common than
visual ones so it is possible she was
hallucinating either visual or sound or
both mm-hmm and that if she had maybe
had some other hallucinations in the
past she could have been incorrectly
diagnosed with schizophrenia but
typically someone wouldn't diagnose you
with schizophrenia and you just had
bipolar hmm it's true but it's also not
it's safe to say that just because she
was diagnosed with bipolar disorder that
she was not also schizophrenic and was
undiagnosed that is also possible
mm-hmm either way doesn't explain how
she got in that water tower but I did
want to clarify thank you for that
that's important all right the next one
is called the man from torrid this is so
lit this source this is my favorite [ __ ]
the source from this is anomaly infocom
anomaly is low calm not our sponsors
okay I'll just kind of read you the it
was like this corner written very story
like so I'm gonna read it as is because
I feel like it does
the best job of painting a picture on a
hot day in July 1954 officials at the
Tokyo Airport in Japan were confronted
with a puzzling problem a travel from
Europe with a passport for a country
called torrid ta u re D as that as the
traveler looked European not Japanese
claimed his country was in Europe and
carried money from several European
countries the airport officials felt
that there had to be a simple
explanation why they didn't know what
this country was on his passport so they
pulled him over to a room and started to
ask him questions as he tried to locate
the information on torrid the traveller
started to become angry he stated this
was his third trip this year to Japan
for his company and he been making such
trip for the past five years and he
couldn't understand what the hell this
delay was for approving a trip that he's
taken so many times but the company he
claims to be coming to visit said they
the official said they didn't know what
it was and they couldn't even find proof
that the company was a thing let alone
that he claimed to work for it the hotel
also claimed that he did not have
reservations or did they know who he was
he could speak Japanese very well among
other languages he was seemingly further
proof of his previous contact with Japan
with Japan he spoke French natively and
was genuinely shocked that he could not
find his country on a world map
presented to him by the officials he
stated that his country was located
where the map showed the principal of
Andorra along with parts of France and
Spain said that turret had existed for
almost a thousand years so it should
have been on the map not surprisingly he
soon demanded talk to government
officials government officials to clear
the matter up since he couldn't be
detained to the airports room overnight
they put him in a in a room at a nearby
hotel that was guarded overnight to
immigration officials were set to guard
the room the unknown traveler was not to
leave till the authorities have made a
decision on the whole problem he would
serve dinner his room soon went to sleep
it had been a long day for him though
the door to his room was guarded all
night when they checked in the morning
he and his belongings were completely
gone the only other exit was a Ledge
list window high above a busy street the
traveler was gone never to be heard from
again which solved the Amidah problem
for the officials right how do we find
this lost man's country and what is what
is he doing here
but it left's a larger problem for the
world to discover who was the man from
torrid he come from an alternate
dimension as some have guessed many
websites pondering this even pointing
out the initial reports of the matter
come from calling Wilson's book the
directory of possibilities published
well before the internet was a thing so
this is not some your internet story but
a genuine paranormal mystery that may
never be solved maybe paranoia so
interesting interesting interesting so
many things about us are interesting one
thing that jumps out of me is that he
says my country has existed for a
thousand years yet he's still traveling
by airport so the alternate universe the
alternate reality alternate dimension
seems like the most the most plausible
thing here he said you mean he still
travels by airport you're really far
away from the mic I can't really hear
that well what I'm saying is he he
literally got on an airplane and flew
there if he was gonna freak out about
the technology he would probably done it
then right though that's what I'm saying
like he's not from the future
he's from now but in an alternate
universe right yeah yeah that's what I'm
saying I'm not saying what I'm saying is
like I think he's from adjust that there
was it was cross dimensions he got put
into the wrong time but seem same time
just in a different dimension and so I
don't know what do you think we yeah
that's exactly what I think I love that
I think it's so cool
and he had a passport from the country
torrid right stumped officials right
that they like what is this country yeah
and the fact that he was also they there
was no body at the base of that building
he didn't jump out and kill himself
right where did he go did he find the
portal and go back to his his property
man I don't it for someone like that
that doesn't seem like he even knew that
he had shifted dimensions obviously this
was an accident so somebody came to pick
up the pieces and it's called the
Orville
[Music]
Jason okay but imagine I know imagine if
this is you right or make me magic isn't
me I go to the airport tomorrow like hey
I gotta go to Minneapolis and they're
just like mini what and I'm like right
here mini ambos and I point to the map
and it's called gurgle GRU I'm like
that's not where that is mm-hmm and
they're like what do you mean
Minneapolis what are you even going for
I'm like the Superbowl they're like the
Superbowl has it happened in hundreds of
years and I'm just like what are you
talking about yeah but or the Superbowl
doesn't exist or what is the Superbowl I
think that for someone that and this is
all totally theory obviously but for
someone that's what what are you doing
for someone that like switches timelines
or dimensions or alternate realities I
don't think that they're aware of it you
know if people were aware of it then
they would likely have studied it and
control it so or try to harness it as a
thing I think anyone that's ever jumped
a time liner and to an alternate
dimension has never meant to it's been
an accident so I don't think he escaped
or disappeared I feel like some other
being was like whoops and just plucked
out and threw him back into his
dimension or some force of the universe
did it yes not a person he had a limited
amount of time to exist in this
dimension before he just naturally
disappeared yeah like what if he was
gone from both dimensions after this
totally he accidentally slipped out of
his dimension went to briefly to a
different one right parallel to his and
then was disintegrated because he
couldn't be there for that long it's
interesting to think about like when
it's put in terms of like just normal
travel right like you like I said like
say I'm going to Minnesota and aha
no any nobody knows where Minnesota is
and it's not part of the map and I'm so
I'm so in like in my brain I'm so
positive of like the fact that that's a
real place and I know it exists and that
I know I'm going there it's like the
Mandela effect on stir
it's like little things that we'd
remember as Berenstein bears eventually
if you know you put your imagination to
it it could become bigger and bigger and
bigger yes to where you're like I swear
but there's everywhere was a country
called torrid near France and Spain and
then maybe it affects literally everyone
everyone is on the same page except for
you and you're the only one that's like
y'all don't [ __ ] remember tarik
because that's where I'm from
it's a good way to put it them in dawa
effect on steroids yeah it's like but
maybe that's all that shifting
dimensions is wow wow that's gotten the
gears moving right that's interesting
it's like it's the same life
everything's the same except things are
slightly different that you saw if they
happen
then it's larger change like a piece of
land or a body of water instead of just
like the name of a children's book hold
on I have a question then does that mean
that we are living in a slightly
alternated universe or slightly
alternated timeline than the one we
might have grown up on it's totally
possible
um yeah does that explain the Mendel
effect basically it doesn't it doesn't
good it could in theory though it
couldn't theory right like
one-one linear dimension of time not
linear one dimension sorry what I'm
trying to think of the word what is the
word for whatever one dimension of time
is us as kids it was spelled Berenstein
bears then we slightly shifted and we're
adults everything's pretty much the same
except now it's berenstain bears mm-hmm
is that kind of what you're saying
that's the middle of it okay so you're
saying this okay this is [ __ ]
interesting well oh so this happened in
1954 mm-hm the country according to him
had existed for quote a thousand or
thousands
ah let me see
genuinely shocked locating or not
surprisingly might be on the first page
hold on what did they say was that was
what did the number thousand come into
play where was like said my country has
existed for he either said you I didn't
understand if you said a thousand or
thousands of years almost a thousand
years so it should have been on the map
so in 1954 that means it's been around
since 1854 no that's hundred that's a
hundred years summarizes this is the
eleven hundred or thousand not like nine
hundred that would be a thousand years
said almost so yeah yeah you had it
right then okay so if we have if if in
your lifetime you have a Mandela effect
that's relatively small like a
children's book over the course of a
thousand years maybe that's enough
Mandela effect for it country just
completely not exist and somehow he
shifted a time line differently at a
different time than everyone else did or
like got pushed
instead of like slowly going through it
where you don't realize it maybe when he
got on that airplane for him in his
current reality it like completely
shifted a thousand years worth of
Mandela effects for him to fully feel
the effects of all the languages are the
same most of the countries are exciting
airports at the same my country as a
whole just doesn't it but it was just
that day because he had traveled to
Japan or he trout yabbies in Japan's
Airport so he had gotten to Japan from
torrid likely to him or you know
according to him according him you've
done it before
yes that day yeah he like shifted across
the time and space continue to the point
where he's so confused his country
doesn't even exist
anymore imagine the [ __ ] freak out
you'd have if you go to the airport and
you're just like what in the world do
you mean the United States of America is
in a country yeah it says it right here
on my passport I can point to it on a
map I have it on my iPhone and I see
roomful of officials government
officials flabbergasted at my passport
it's probably just as freaky on both
sides yeah I think that he had shifted
dimensions or I think I think that's the
only I wish they took a picture of his
passport yeah it says it's documented
right
yeah it's 1954 they could have taken a
picture right yeah yeah and I wish they
took a picture of his passport
show us the tour ID passport it could
totally be in there government documents
they haven't released it that's possible
I'm shooting a quick Google search
torrid Passport
what do you think it looked like that's
a torrid on it good guess what I
searched google image toward passport
and it said there is no internet
connection Oh are we are we shifting is
this it yeah I think this is it
access denied dude what is happening
okay I got the picture it says cancelled
there's a big stamp across it this is
cancelled so they cancelled his torrid
Passport that's rude oh my god this is
wild tourist visa 19 March 25th 1999 one
[ __ ] was maybe there isn't a picture of
it huh this might be it
yeah I don't know I couldn't make a look
for hours anyway that one's that one's
probably the most interesting to me I
like I like stuff like that too because
it's not dark like noni disappeared
you know something I did but he's
probably fine
mr. torrid we hope your country wins a
million medals in the Olympics doesn't
exist torrid man that's well okay well
that's gonna wrap it up for these
unsolved mysteries if you guys want us
to do more of these
first of all go on Twitter and thank
invented by Jenna for these because she
has an incredible threat of these like
she must have spent so many hours on it
and we will revisit this for a party
because I genuinely want to do more of
these yeah I agree
also let me know how wrong I was on
every one of these in the comments below
you just read the story I probably
missed something it's okay yeah those
are fun thank you guys for hanging out
sad and scary but it's not and scary fun
interesting well we'll see you guys next
week for another podcast my Julie comes
home I will be home hopefully you guys
have a wonderful week and uh tonight we
will be on Twitch live via the power of
the Internet from the country of torrid
there should be a video game like based
on that that's right like you know the
closing point of the game is like you've
made it back to torrid and your similar
timeline like the beginning of the game
you open up and you're just getting on a
flight to Tokyo and then they detain you
or whatever and then you spend the
entire game just trying to figure out
how to get back every time [ __ ] god
she [ __ ] a that's pretty lit up right
me done they should name the next pub
GMaps torrent door thank you guys for
hanging out hope you have a wonderful
week we'll see you tonight on Twitch and
[Music]
[Music]